tedros w.h.o
many of these these multinational
institutions not just the
non-governmental ones but the corporate
ones do
fall under this liberal blob and they
are so happy
these guys are back in power you want to
see how creepy this is
there's a there's a clip going around
you've maybe you've heard about the
conspiracy theory of the great
reset or you know the idea that that a
lot of liberal people are going to
exploit the coronavirus issue to
reset society rework the economy rework
various political orders
so radical crazy conspiracy i have no
idea
where they would have gotten this idea
from it's a very pertinent question
to ask how do we build that better to
build back better or whatever
we have a chance to reset the clock and
build back
better than before to build back better
than before
remember the the terrible damage of
covid as we try to build back
from this uh global pandemic joe biden
calls it build back better
build back better building back
better to do things differently to build
back better we're going to build it back
better and build it back better
in my plan to build back better
uh start taking all the problems that
have been created in education and
mental health and start to
to build back in a positive way i have
launched
a booklet called build back better
britain after coronavirus
it's about building this country back
better
growing conspiracy following it it is
called
the great reset unprecedented
opportunity
to rethink and reset the ways in which
we live
that clip could go on for several more
minutes okay
so i i understand that some people get
kooky with their
their theories about these kind of
cabals of evil elites ruling the world
i don't think you need any kind of
conspiracy theory
people in public the liberal elite in
public are coming out saying yes we're
going to use this as an opportunity
to rework the economy to rework society
to rework the political order
there's no question about that there's
obviously cooperation going on
not just among the liberal blob in the
united states but around the world
this idea of building back
better this idea of some people are
calling it the great reset
i don't really use that term because it
sounds conspiratorial
and it sounds like secret and nefarious
it certainly is nefarious but it's all
out in public
you have plenty of of these liberal
elites
some of the elected politicians and many
unelected people describing this
and the way that one builds back better
or the way the one reset society is
is not really done through democratic
politics
in a way it is you'll some of these
people are elected but mostly how this
will be done
is at the administrative level or at the
corporate level
also beyond the realm of of democratic
accountability
when you put people out of work for nine
months ten months it's more than that
now i guess i guess we're coming up on a
year aren't we
when you put people out of work for that
long you
you make them much more vulnerable to
these sort of plans you
you gin up society you encourage the
sort of riots that we saw all year long
you clamp down on political rights now
you can't you can't go to church
still in many places you could always go
buy a dime bag of pot in california
you could always go to those
essential services but you couldn't go
to church
and the excuse for this was public
health well who runs the public health
it's this bureaucracy it's this
doctor dictatorship it's dr fauci
liberated and where
where do our liberties go with that
liberation
very very creepy